did you find like when you got sober you
had to get rid of certain friends or
certain people in your circle
um no i don't think so because i think i
was very smart and choosing who i
surround myself with yeah i mean like i
can really name who's my friends in
terms of my acquaintances right but
it definitely
helped me to tell him like yo like you
got to get off this [ __ ] or like
tone it down a bit
like i still got friends that are on
drugs yeah 100 they're on their [ __ ]
but like they definitely tone down than
what they were because i'm sure like at
a certain point in time your fans
probably also had to be like leaving
comments like bro chill out like yeah
that would say chill especially once the
the fat epidemic started but yeah i've
been clean i i haven't touched pills or
lean in like two over two and a half
years i don't smoke wheat anymore bro
congrats don't even smoke weed i get
panic attacks like back in the day i can
smoke ass now i smoke panic attack panic
attack crazy congratulations man i vape
you do some vaping a little bit of that
liquid tobacco yeah